well we are talking all things
decorating today it's kind of the
unofficial official day for holiday
decor i've got joanne vitale joining me
from whiskey skies boutique and and here
is just a beautiful display but i have
to ask the most important thing when
you're decorating your home for the
holidays what would that be
you can do it on a budget not everything
has to be a crazy price you have a lot
of items at home that you can reuse
every single day in your holiday decor
okay so stuff that you already have
let's jump on that first because people
at home might be wondering how do i do
this i i don't have any extra funds
right now what look at that tell me
about this this is one of my favorite
things to do most of us have a wine
glass at home especially during the
holiday season you can just add a little
string of lights in there a cute little
bottle uh brush tree and then a little
candle right there on top that's a
beautiful centerpiece it's very
festive and like you said you already
have it yep i love it now a lot of these
items here are under 20 which is great
for people who are being budget
conscious this holiday season
what's the theme here what are people
excited about this year we're seeing a
lot of everything traditional christmas
gingerbread have been really hot uh
gingerbread houses okay
tons of gingerbread man well they're not
here we have tons and sees you have tons
okay of course whiskey skies is online
so that's where folks can do the
shopping but they can pick it up here so
you can shop online whiskeysguys.com you
can grab a free app we have an app store
we stream live in our app and then you
can also do porch pickup um right there
at our warehouse so you don't have to
worry about your package being delayed
so that makes it really easy for folks
at home now i know this isn't the under
20 but i have to show this off here
because this i've never seen anything
quite like that yes it's gorgeous it's
one of our exclusive designs it just hit
our shop literally yesterday just in
time today for black friday it is
gorgeous with all the glitter
and glitter is kind of the way to go for
the holidays right you can't can you
have too much glitter no okay and this
you can use year-round
different holidays valentine's day
coming up after christmas i know we're
already talking about that joanne thank
you so much have a beautiful display
folks at home just go to whiskey skies
they are online and happy decorating